hi I'm Jennifer Hudson I'm from the film
cats hi I'm Francesca Hayward's
I play Victoria in cats hey what's up
people I'm Jason Derulo here with cats
play with kittens Wow answering fan
questions you don't want me to be your
mom I know you do
my first reaction when I saw myself as a
cat I couldn't identify myself I
actually thought I was Jason Derulo you
know it's insane how the characters come
to life a lot of things you have no idea
like what it'll look like I was just
really excited you know I remember
watching it like three four times when I
first seen it just because you know just
visually it's just so stimulating the
glamour in Grizabella I feel like I
related to the most didn't uh feel like
a we have a similar story it's a certain
extent she comes with a depth she has
the glamour but yes I was sakers Abela
I'm not gonna hurt you any kids I like
my character Victoria a lot because I
like a personality that she's curious
but she's also she's kind and
good-hearted and she's also pretty brave
and she's kind of unpredictable where
did you go you definitely relates to rum
tum tugger the most I don't know if it's
because I played him but I think he's
kind of like myself you know sometimes
we get so caught up in life that we
forget to stop and smell the roses
you know Zed and he in and he's you know
he he's a playboy much like myself too
[Music]
playing on the set you should see the
set it's everything is magnified from a
cat's perspective like imagine these
kitties
this room is enormous as humans we don't
see it that way so to go in the set
everything is magnified like a kitchen
sink would be a bathtub to a cat and all
of us hunted to children playing on the
set of cats I have a great memory of
seeing Judi Dench just snuggled up in a
cat basket that's a pretty good memory
James Corden is hilarious rebel Wilson
is hilarious
you know you get them in a room and like
you just can't stop laughing so like
some of my favorite moments words were
what my banter was my dancer with with
rebel probably a lot of the stuff we
probably can't keep cuz it was so dirty
and it's a family movie but it was just
hilarious hilarious
I think the dancers were best at
planning cat
I think Francesca was amazing as well
everybody because the thing is we all
got to create our own cats like us as
humans we're all individuals although we
have similar characteristics and many
reasons but we use it in our own ways
but we did that as cats and it was
helpful being with the ensemble of
dancers and you mirror them because they
specialize in movement so I felt like
they were most inspiring as to know how
to move cat-like I think we all had our
own way of being a cat so it was really
interesting seeing like everyone's
different taken I'm definitely best at
playing the cat obviously the less twins
I feel like you know we're really really
solid their movement is is really crazy
and you know it'd be like being a dancer
you know it helps out a ton and there's
some of them
cuttable dances in the world so I feel
like they don't read really powerful it
was a process that when I first heard
about light we got no casting wait huh
you maybe I get wait what the key for it
to me or for me was sniffing because I
makes you more animalistic like they we
realized like as humans we use our eyes
or to enter a place or to guide us or
cats they use their senses did you know
when they put their paws on your face
they're laying their scent on you and
you become fierce aha so let's see what
we do as humans to do that I don't know
what we do but they have their own way
to be social and things like that
like right now they are loving each
other but that makes sense we kind of
had to do like the cat school was like
toast to the importance we had to do a
lot of imagining of like so we could
imagine where I thought layers would be
in our tale so that we could do all that
putting on the suit and being like
programmed into the computer we had to
do they come proper to call calibrating
we had to do that I can calibrate
ourselves twice a day to the computer so
that was part of like the process of
getting ready in the morning so I guess
yeah all in all it took me about like an
hour to get ready every day we'd get in
really early and then we'd have to put
on our green suits but then he would
have to sit in makeup for you know like
30 to 40 minutes and it's not like
getting made up for for camera it's more
like CGI me this was a bunch of dots but
there's also a slight color
discoloration um by the way you can look
so like you know for me you know they
would have to put like white here and
then like a little white here so you get
the dots but then it's just for
referencing
kind of kind of make your your you know
cabin looked like you kinda a little bit
[Music]
so I recently just got two cats which is
named macavity and Grizabella and all
they do is sleep all day and relax
they're my cuddle buddies I feel like
they getting cats was the best decision
I made this year and they relaxed me
like they are chillin like when I left
them this morning they were laid up
relaxing that's what I would do if I was
a cat and then it looks so good doing
everything if they're so elegant they
have such great presence in the way they
move is so commanding maybe I didn't
want to be a cat I always get everyone's
give me lots of attention so I can get
all my favorite foods and then I
probably spend a lot of time sleeping
would be like a great day off I'd be
just like a cat I'd be lazy give me some
milk you know I'm saying a little cream
Oh what do you want wait what do you go
you go that was an interesting feeling
you ever had a cat crawl up your jacket
I don't want to put it out again I
almost feel like the musicals choose me
versus me choosing them I have to say
the same it was the same for Dreamgirls
as it is for cats like when Tom Hooper
came to see me about being Grizabella
and cats he's like you know cats and I'm
like I feel like I heard of cats in
there
he's like you know memory and announcer
who then when he played the sound like
of course everyone knows memory but I
never saw the play I never saw
Dreamgirls either but I knew and I'm
telling you I knew I'm changing
well I know memory as well I actually
love that musical ragtime I don't know
if it's that known you know if you're
not a musical lover but I think it's a
brilliant story the music is fantastic
it was definitely one that I you know I
see myself you know I'm doing as a film
so many good people the Performa do what
within this caste but the first name
would come to mind is take this with so
many great singers in the cast cast and
have to switch you have Jennifer Hudson
even James Corden is a brilliant singer
I knew Sex in the City was like the
hottest show around but I had never
watched that show either but until I
started like prepping for it and then I
went like crazy watching Sex in the City
and I fell in love with it from there
and obviously not so part of my life
from working with the cast of Sex in the
City
it's like being one of the girls in Sex
in the City is like a drink who wouldn't
want to be a part of that and to set it
to be able to say I'm released from st.
Louis catch it it's a fashion honor I
think
I already just be told that I was
singing was pretty overwhelming because
IFC didn't train in singing I didn't
train as a singer I trained the dancers
so just to be singing at all it was
pretty crazy for me and then to be told
that I was doing it with like to be half
of the song written by like Taylor Swift
was just absolutely incredible and she
sang it to me for the first time like a
private concert in a very anticipatory
birth and what I had about the part of
Victoria and I really wanted to audition
because when I was little I used to
watch the video of the stage musical in
my living room like when I was about 7
or 8 and I would always I would invite
my friends around and I was pay the part
of Victoria and make them like dance to
all the other cats and I would always be
Victoria and bounce around so yeah it
was definitely a dream come true to get
a chance to audition and just wanted to
go for it haha so now they won't be
cat-themed some of them unfortunately or
fortunately actually what that album
really stands for is is you know when
you walk out the door in the morning
sometimes you know we paint that picture
that we want people to see you know of
ourselves and this album will show both
of that and the side that people don't
see many thanks for Best Friends Animal
Society for bringing these adorable
kittens today to find out more about
best friends work to save homeless dogs
and cats and how you can help go to best
friends org to get more info come here
little buddy
[Music]